i grew up very poor in a big family we  were on food stamps we would dumpster  dive for food a lot of people find it  hard to believe that i was ever that  poor i look like i was conceived at an  ivy league acapella concert  my dad owns every university she may do  about what is adversity  five minutes up the road is a boys  basketball camp that i really wanted to  go to because my mom wants to save that  little bit of money she goes why don't  you just attend the cheerleading camp  with your sisters  basically the same thing  we get to go up to the boys camp and  cheer them on  during one of their games  all right boys show us what you got  show us what you got boy show us what  you got  [Applause]  no i don't know if you've ever had to  cheer someone on  as they bully you  but it's a lot like if someone shot you  and then it was your job to reload their  gun for them  you